I remember Anthropic saying, "Oh, this
is our thing, Claude."  And I thought, "
What a strange name, Claude."  As if
she were saying, "What?"  And yes, now it's
like: "Oh, yes, Claude."  You know, we get
used to it.  If Claude does
enough work for you, you think, "
Oh, he's my best friend."  I love Claude.
Yes, but was that what they came up with
? That? Was that the best they
could do?
This is Dalton and Michael, and today we're going to
talk about how to build a brand.
So, I heard that you guys are
starting some kind of
branding agency here.
We love...we love brands.  Step one:
hire a branding agency.  Step
two: profits.  That's all.  That's the
two-step plan.  Well, I thought there were
three.  I think you have to pay
the branding agency a lot of money.
I think that goes without saying.  Um...
Look, I think we're being a little
ironic because this is an example
where we're the first to admit that
branding is very important and that if
you want to build a
major company, you need a great brand.
Yes.
Now, what might make us roll our
eyes a little is the
process by which a founder
believes a brand is created.  TRUE?
You want to... I
know, yes.  So...
you even want to make this video, Mike.    So
, that's how much you don't like
talking about branding.
Yes. Let's say, spam people,
seek press coverage, try to get
as many speaking engagements as
humanly possible, do weird tricks
ad infinitum;  Basically, not understanding
how much of your brand is being
built by the service you
provide to your customers.
Yes.
And I think I'll go even further
.  I don't know, the phrase "word of mouth"
used to be very popular in the past and
I feel like it has completely disappeared
.  For better or for worse,
your customers' experience with your product is
probably the greatest brand strength
for your entire company.  And so, if
you want to build your brand, make sure
your next customer loves your
product.  The amount of brand value
that will generate for you is 10 times greater
than almost anything else you can
do to build your brand.  So
how...? Why were people
confused by this?
I think the anti-pattern is that, like
most things in life, it's
convenient to believe you can hire
a service provider...
Yes,
to get what you want.
We have a great product.  We do
n't have a brand yet.  So if
you have a consultant,
you want to believe that you can buy the
product fit to the market.
Yes.
You want to believe you can buy
users.
Yes.
You want to believe you can buy
great employees.  As, as we want to
believe, you know, we'll probably still
fall for this, man.  You know, we
're not, we're not above
this, but you think, "How do I
just buy the best and take a
shortcut and jump straight to the good stuff and not
have to, you know, do all this
work?"  Isn't that what we all
want?  And then, the brand is one
of those things where you say, "Yeah, yeah, you
know, Apple is a really
good brand."  Who can I pay to make
us Apple?  To have your own
brand.  It's like, we hire Johnny
Ive and that's it, great, now we're
Apple?  It's that easy.
And this is what bothers me, because, you
know, we grew up when Steve
Jobs revitalized Apple.  If we could
summarize what Apple did very,
very succinctly, it's that they made products
that we were very excited to buy.
Yeah.
And when our friends had the
iPod and we didn't, it was like, "Oh
man, that's awesome."  And I suppose I
remember some advertisements.  But
do I remember any advertisements?    There
are no shortcuts.  I understand that,
I suppose this is, this is
probably not what you want to hear,
audience, but it is built by fulfilling
a promise over and over and over and over again
enough times for that to
be, that to be your brand.  Your brand is
defined by what you do over and over again
in all your actions and in
every interaction your customers
have with your product.
Well, I think the unfortunate
truth is that, very often, when a
founder has a graph that's going up to
the right, they assume their product
works.  And then they ask themselves this
question: "Okay, how do we get more
momentum?"  "How do we get more
distribution?"  "How do we improve the
brand?"  And the unfortunate thing is how
frequently I see a graph that
goes like this, and then like this, and then like this.
Yes.
Because people try the product,
subscribe for that year of blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, and if the product delivers,
great, but it almost always doesn't.  And
when their friends tell them about it,
they say, "Oh, okay. We're
testing it, blah, blah, blah." When their
company says to them, "Hey, can you use
this?"  And you respond, "Shut up. I don't
want to use this shitty new tool
." And then they leave.
And the time you spent building your
brand, if you had spent it
solving the customer's problem so they'd
say, "Oh, I love working
with this company."
One hundred percent.
You have personal experience, you know,
with some of the most
iconic brands in the world, and you know how they
were built. So, let's talk about
Reddit for a second, you know, for
context. You're on the board of
directors of Reddit, and Steve is your
friend.
Yeah. And they were friends since they were
kids, basically.
From the very beginning, yeah. I mean, so
what was it like? Did he hire
someone for branding? Did he say something like,
"Tell me how to make Reddit the
most important website in the world"? Or
yeah, what did he actually do?
You know, there was this
interesting, somewhat famous conversation between Steve and
PG that I heard about, which
was basically: "Suppose there are a lot of people like
you on the internet, and make something that you
really, really enjoy using." And it
was like giving Steve permission to
basically think: if I like it
, other people will like it. So,
let me make something that I love. You know,
it's funny because Reddit used to not
have subreddits. It was just one
thing. And Reddit got pretty big
before it had to create subreddits and
all that other stuff, because it turns out
Steve wasn't a one-
off snowflake, and there are a lot of people who...
Well, the original subreddit... There was only
one subreddit, and it was Steve's.
Yeah, exactly.
He moderated Reddit like it was his
own personal subreddit.
Exactly. And then, people like Steve. And
for me, I think that was like...
Amazing. I think, you know, in the
history of Justin.tv and Twitch,
right? Our brand didn't even
matter until we realized
Who were our customers,
right? The moment we
realized that our true
customers were the streamers, everything
changed, right? I'd say for
the first five years of the company,
the brand was basically irrelevant.
We hadn't identified the user
we could actually help.
Piracy—the case of piracy—
it turns out that those who owned the
content didn't really like it being
redistributed. When we discovered
that these streamers wanted to make
money and were looking for great support and a
great platform, we started serving them
really well, and then they started creating
more content. That was the
positive cycle, and serving our
streamers well is what built our
brand. And I remember there was a time when
our CEO, Kevin, we had
a competitor who basically offered
all our top streamers
a ton of money. He did all the
calculations and just said, "This isn't
working." So he had the courage to
basically say to them, "Hey, we can't
match this."  I understand if you
want to go with them, but if for
some reason it doesn't work out, know that we
love you and you can come back anytime.
" A lot of people left.
Three months later, when they were supposed to
receive their first check, guess
what happened? No checks arrived because
the company that ripped people off
couldn't monetize them either. Every single one of
those people came back. Turns out, not
lying to your users is how
you build a brand. And I think there's
this misconception
, and this is what's always so
painful, because how often is
the answer to why your company
failed that you didn't actually
serve your users
well enough? That's like a 99
% chance. Like a 99%
chance that you didn't figure out
how to make enough of an impact on
your users' businesses, lives, jobs, or whatever. Do you know of any companies
that had a huge impact on
users' lives but
failed because of their branding?
No, I can't think of any.
It's hard to see it with fresh eyes, but
I remember the Airbnb name and logo
as the worst thing I've ever seen.  Never. It
was all spelled out.
It was, it was spelled out, it's just
like
Airbnbandbreakfast.com.
It's like the least appealing brand name I can think of
. And it's everywhere. And
again, we all just kind of got
used to it. Um, and that's a
really important thing. You know, I remember
Anthropic, they're like, "Oh, this is
our thing, Claude." And I'm like, "That's
a weird name." Claude? Is it like,
what?
And again, now it's like, "Yeah, Claude
." You know, we got used to it.
Well, if you're like Claude, he's a
perfect example. If Claude does
enough work for you, you're like, "He's
my best friend."
I love Claude.
Yeah, but was that what they came up with
? Was that...was that the best they
could do? And well, at the end of the
day, we've seen a lot of
iconic brands that seem like normal things
the founders came up with,
become huge, and it's not because
they spent money on branding. I mean, there's
one right now. I can't watch
TV without  I see them mention
Calsh.
Yeah.
And you funded them for YC. You're their
first investor. And they never really
changed their name. They never changed their
logo.
No.
But now it's like, sure, it looks like
a really big brand, right, man?
Like, super ads and stuff.
Hey, do they even know what Calsh means
? Like, no. What is Calsh? I don't
even know what Calsh means.
It's a thing. I forgot what it is. It's a
thing. It's a thing. It's a thing.
But they just kind of made it up,
and it was in their
YC application.
What's so interesting about this is
, um, winning is really hard. And I think
sometimes in the startup game
, in the tech game, maybe you get
confused about branding because you're like, "
What...what can I learn from other
businesses?"  "."TRUE?  "And it's like,
well, if you're selling, you know,
ice cream in the supermarket aisle,
and it's fundamentally a commodity
, maybe you'd have a
different conversation about branding,
right? Like, you know, I always
think of Talenti ice cream, which has
that...transparent,
yeah,
container, so you can see the
ice cream inside, and it's like, honestly
, if your surface of innovation is the
logo and the packaging, then maybe you
're having a
different conversation, maybe that
branding conversation is more relevant in that arena.
Compared to if
your product surface here is like, 'Oh, it's
doing all these things for
consumers, or all these things for
business.'"  It's probably much
more complicated than a logo and
transparent packaging. So
maybe the mistake people make is
like, "Oh, I'm trying to learn
branding techniques from these other
businesses and apply them here." Do you think
that's happening a little bit?  "
Sure. And again, to give you
another point of reference, you know,
Whatnot, I funded them for YC, it
launched. Same name, they never
changed their name.
Yeah. They made their website look
a little better, but it's the same W with
yellow. It's the same branding, man.
So, having seen these things
that are now like household names on
the App Store, yeah, it seems like
a surprisingly
small amount of effort went into branding. And that
the real effort was in everything
else. So, again, let's try to make
this real and not just like, 'Hey,
founder, why would you ask
about this?'"  "I think you should define
: What is my startup trying to do?"
Yes. Who are we trying to serve?
What do we want to excel at?  And your
brand is your ability to articulate
those things and deliver on them.  And if you can't
articulate that, no amount of
branding will help you.  So, what are you
even trying to do?  And you say
: "I don't know, things for people."  That, you
know, that's not going to work.  And
then I think you have to know what
you stand for, right?
I think what I would tell
founders is assume that your product
is failing you, not your brand, and you will be
right more often than you are
wrong.  And when you,
your team members, or even your users
tell you that your product is great, be
skeptical.  I think you have to be
skeptical, and the best companies
improve great products.  The best
companies can take a product that
's great and make it better and better.  And they do
n't have that mentality of: "we made
a great product, now what?".  "
Now let's work on our brand,
now let's work on our sales and
our brand."
Yes, a brand is not something separate, it is
part of the whole.
It's part of everything and is the result of
consistently creating great products
over time.
So why do people change their
brand? Why do you need to?    I
'm just trying to think of one from
memory.  Do you remember the company
called Zen Payroll?
Yes.
And then they changed to Gusto.  I'm still not
sure I love the
name Gusto because it's very generic,
but it was because they wanted to do more than just
payroll.
Yes, that made sense.  Again, that's why
I understand why you would change it.
Yes.
But let's be clear.  It's not like
they changed their name to Gusto and then
became a unicorn.  It wasn't
like, "
No," it was more like they simply
had to do it.
Yes, they wanted to attract customers who were
looking for, uh, health insurance.
I mean, we changed it because we were going
from watching just anything to watching
video games.    That
makes sense.
You might be able to do something to make your
brand less confusing, but switching
from Justin TV gaming to Twitch didn't make
Twitch grow.
It's curious.  It seems that the problem that
much of the rebranding is trying to solve
is the company's internal politics
.  And that's my most
charitable explanation for why Google has so
many products with
confusingly similar names.  For example,
how many chat products do they have? And
their AI offerings? Could you name which
AI products Google releases?  We have
Gemini, we have, you know, there are like 20
of them.  And I think it's only because they are
different teams.  I think that's an
organizational chart problem.
Yes, that's correct.
HBO Go was renamed a bunch of times
, all that mess.
Max, Go, HBO Max.
Yes, and I think it's just because of
internal nonsense.  So I'm pretty
sure that when you see companies
doing a lot of branding exercises or
rebranding, it's because there's a
specific reason that makes sense, or you
're witnessing a symptom of
internal politics being exposed to the
outside world.
I'd say maybe one more, Comcast
Xfinity.  Maybe you're just running away from
a horrible, horrible reputation.
Hopefully you're not in that
situation.  Okay, that's our
guide.  Good luck with your
brand consultants.
Very well, thank you Michael.  Good chat
.  Yes.
Mhm.